you are at a parisian cafe with a friend
a local in front of you buys a cup of
coffee and a croissant for five dollar
or five thirty euro
when you and your friend get two cups of
coffee and two croissants you are
charged 14 euro can we solve for the
price of a cup of coffee and croissant
using the information in a system of
linear equations and two variables if
yes what is the solution if no what is
the reason we cannot so we're looking
for two things the price of a cup of
coffee and the price of a croissant so
let's define two variables here let's
let
since we have all these c's here i'm
just going to use x's and y's so let's
let x
let's let x be equal to the price
of the cup of coffee
cup of coffee
and let's let
y
be equal to the price of a croissant
price of a
croissant
so we first have this information of
what the local in front of us did the
local in front of us buys one cup of
coffee and one croissant for 5 30 euro 5
5 well 5.3 euro you could even say so
how would we set that up as an equation
well we got one cup of coffee so that's
going to be 1x or we could just write it
x
plus 1y because he got one croissant and
it cost
530. so it cost let me write this so
this is the amount that he paid
5 30 euro 5 30. so this is what the
local this this equation describes what
happened to the local bought one cup of
coffee one croissant paid 530.
now when you and your friend get two
cups of coffee and two croissants you're
charged 14 euro so what's an equation to
describe this so we should be charged
two times the price of a cup of coffee
so it should be 2x
and then we should be charged 2 times
the price of a croissant so plus 2y
and the sum of these should be the total
amount that we're charged we've been
charged 14
14 euro
14 euro so let's see if we can solve
this system of equations and there's
many many many ways to solve this but
the most obvious way at least looking at
this right over here is here we have x
we have 2x we have y we have 2i let's
take this first equation that described
the local and multiply it by 2.
so let's just multiply it by 2. so we're
going to multiply both sides otherwise
the equality won't hold anymore
so we would get
2x
plus 2y
is equal to 2 times 530 is 10.60 or 10
euro 60
10
euro 60. now something very interesting
is going on here
if the local had bought just twice as
many twice as many cups of coffee and
twice as many croissants he would have
paid 10.60 and that would have been the
exact amount of coffee and croissants
you got and you paid 14. so it looks
pretty clear that you got charged a
different amount you got the tourist
rate for the cup of coffee in the
croissant while he got the local rate
and we can verify that there's no x and
y that's going to satisfy this even
logically it makes sense here 2 times an
x plus 2 times y is 14. here 2 times an
x plus 2 times y is 10. 10 euros 60 and
we can even show that mathematically
that this doesn't make sense so if we
were to subtract this bottom equation
from this top so essentially you could
imagine multiplying so let me just do it
this way multiplying the entire bottom
equation times a negative 1. so let's
multiply the entire bottom equation by a
negative 1 and then we add these two
equations remember all we're doing is
we're starting with say this equation
and we're adding the same thing to both
sides we're going to add this to this
side and we already know that negative
1060 is the same thing as this we're
going to add it to that side so on the
left hand side this cancels with this
this cancels with this we're left with
zero and on the right hand side 14 minus
10 60 will get you to 340.
and there's no x and y that you can
think of there's no magical x and y that
can all of a sudden make 0 equal 340. so
there is no solution and the only
explanation over here is that the local
was charged a cheaper rate